[Music]
prince harry and meghan markle are
taking a bite out of the big apple
that's the duke and duchess of sussex on
thursday posing for photos inside one
world trade center they're joined by nyc
mayor bill de blasio his wife and son as
well as new york governor kathy hokel
the visit comes just two weeks after the
20th anniversary of september 11th which
could possibly explain why they're clad
in all black ensembles megan pulled her
hair into a sleek bun and wore a
turtleneck pea coat long dress pants and
black heels as for harry he went with a
classic dark suit and tie
they were also photographed outside the
building mingling with other guests and
taking in the sights
this trip marks the first time harry and
megan have publicly visited the big city
since tying the knot in 2018. it's also
the first time the duchess has been seen
there since her 2019 baby shower ahead
of the birth of their first child
two-year-old son archie
look the duck is so hot he's getting a
drink of water no the rabbit is so hot
he's cooling off his ears that's the sun
and what's that fish
let's turn the page let's see what else
happens and speaking of archie and his
younger sister three-month-old lillabet
e.t has learned that the little ones did
not join their parents on the trip to
new york well archie of course has just
turned two so what a wonderful belated
birthday present for him the arrival of
a little sister he was by all accounts
so excited about the baby growing in
mommy's tummy and i can imagine that um
he's probably one very excited little
two-year-old at the moment and the
novelty of a new baby in the house is
one that i think is going to stay with
the whole family for quite a long time
the sussexes are staying in new york
through the weekend where they're
scheduled to appear at global citizen
live a star-studded event streaming
around the world highlighting the
importance of global vaccine equity it's
an initiative that harry and megan have
passionately supported before back in
may the duke took the stage at the vax
live benefit concert in los angeles in
an effort to call on world leaders to
make sure covet 19 vaccines are
accessible for all this pandemic will
not end
unless we act collectively
with an unprecedented commitment to our
shared humanity
the vaccine must be distributed to
everyone
everywhere
we cannot rest or truly recover
until there is fair distribution to
every corner of the world
you